that's totally fine but men don't want
to deal with that
that's like when I don't Dove anyway
because I mean you don't deal with it
people's gonna switch on accounts off
the river like again the characteristics
of a woman that frees it up to that
capacity is going to have other
implications in that relationship and
again why would you as a man want to
take that risk what kind of implications
are we talking about here so if we're
talking about like promiscuity and the
effect it can have on a relationship
if that man isn't taking all the
biological boxes whereas he probably
would be would have been before if the
woman was less promiscuous the
likelihood is that she's more likely to
stay we quote the statistic before that
70 to 80 of women leave their men it's
not men leaving it's women leaving so if
men are out here having more sex and
women are having more sex but as a
consequence of us both having more sex
you're less likely to stay with me then
what you're doing is causing a problem
to successful relationships so you're
actively breaking up nuclear homes
because you can't maintain your
discipline